do you take any supplements or eat
organs so one of the things that really
pisses me off about the carnivore
Community is you have charlatans in here
that are scamming people and I mean any
diet sphere you end up with charlatans
scamming people but I feel like if I've
only been eating beef and lamb and bison
and salt and water for five years then I
can pretty safely say that you don't
really need organs I don't need organs I
don't take organ supplements I think if
you have an aversion to eating organs
like if you eat liver and you're like
then you shouldn't be just putting it in
a pill and forcing it down so I don't
think you need organs there I said it